صراع النفوذ في منطقه الساحل الافريقي
متوصل بين واشنطن وموسكو التي تعمل على
توسيع وجودها كقوه لا يمكن احتوائها في
القاره السمراء جهود كبيره يتم بذلها من
طرف مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه في المنطقه
هدفها التمدد في البلدان الافريقيه
لمنافسه الغرب تحديدا واشنطن التي تسعى هي
الاخرى لضرب شبكات فاجنر العسكريه
ومصالحها الاقتصاديه فتحركات فاجنر باتت
مصدر قلق كبير بالنسبه للرئيس بايدن الذي
كشف عن استراتيجيه جديده تناولها تقرير
صادر عن صحيفه بوليتيكو يسعى من خلالها
لكبح المساعي الروسيه في المنطقه من خلال
تبادل المعلومات الاستخباراتيه الامريكيه
الحساسه المتعلقه بفاجنر مع الحلفاء في
افريقيا
واقناعهم بتجنب عقد شركات مع هذه المجموعه
بحسب الصحيفه هذا التكتيك يخدم الوظيفه
المزدوجه المتمثله في تنبيه الحلفاء
بالتهديدات واخطار الخصوم بان واشنطن على
درايه بتحركاتهم حيث تم الكشف عن معلومات
استخباراتيه تتعلق بخطه
لاغتيال رئيس تشاد ومحاولتها الوصول الى
مواقع استخراج الموارد الطبيعيه والسيطره
عليها وغير بعيد عن ذلك عرضت واشنطن على
جمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى تدريب جيشها مقابل
طرد قوات فاجنر وفق مقال لصحيفه لوماندا
الفرنسيه وذلك بعد ان تزايد النفوذ الروسي
في كل من السودان وليبيا وزيمبابوي
وبوركينا فاسو وتشاد والنيجر وموزمبيق
وجمهوريه الكونغو الديمقراطيه شبكه فاجنر
التي تسعى لابرام اتفاقيات دفاعيه وامنيه
من بوابه تقديم الدعم لدول افريقيا
تخفي وراء تحركاتها اطمع موسكو التي ترغب
في جعل روسيا احد المشاركين الاقوياء في
القاره
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات